if you've ever listened to a siren
approaching you've heard the familiar
Doppler shift that's interesting Doppler
Christian Doppler and Wolfgang Mozart
grew up in the same town in Salzburg
Austria I like to think they're kind of
enjoying the irony of that fact that
they both have this fascination with
sound and it's phenomena and the
expansion or dilution of the wavelength
of light is exactly the result of a
Doppler shift which is exactly analogous
to the increase in pitch and the
decrease in Pitch that one hears when an
ambulance first approaches you with its
siren on that pitch is increased and
that's called a blue shift meaning it
goes to Shorter sound wavelings or it
goes to higher pitches the same thing
happens in light if you're being
approached by a a police car and you try
to get away from it it's blue lights
will seem slightly more red because it's
effectively moving away from you